وينضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور محمد الهندي
نائب الامين العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور محمد
الهندي بعد 74
يوم ما تقييمكم لما حققته المقاومه حتى
الان بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا يجب ان
نؤكد ان هذه الحرب لا تقودها اسرائيل انما
تقودها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما حدث
في السابع من اكتوبر هو صاعقه ضربت كل
الترتيبات الامريكيه في المنطقه الان
امريكا كانت تعقد تحالف تقود اسرائيل
ليملا الفراغ في المنطقه عندما تنسحب هي
تدريجيا الى مواجهه الصين ومواجهه روسيا
وفق الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه التي
اعلن عنها عام 21 واسرائيل بدات تعقد
تحالفات وتم ترتيبات لها سنوات طويله في
المنطقه سواء المصالحات التي حدثت اعاده
سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه المصالحه
بين السعوديه وبين ايران المصالحه بين
تركيا والامارات
والسعوديه وايضا ترتيب الاتفاقيات العربيه
اتفاقيات مع اسرائيل اتفاقات ابراهام كل
هذه الترتيبات سنوات الولايات المتحده من
اجل الحفاظ على مصالحها والهدف
الاستراتيجي وبناء هذا التحالف الذي تقوده
اسرائيل تاتي غزه المحاصره المجوعه وتقوم
بهذه الصاعقه هذه الصاعقه هي التي ضربت كل
هذه الترتيبات التي اريد من خلالها تسييد
اسرائيل على المنطقه وانهاء القضيه
الفلسطينيه نهائيا اذا جاءت امريكا جاءت
تقاطر كل الغرب لانه اسرائيل هي التي
ذراعهم في المنطقه وتحافظ على مصالحهم
جاؤوا تقاطروا وضعوا هدفا واحدا اساسيا
لهذا العدوان على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهو
اجتثاث المقا قاومه هذا هو ما تريده
امريكا وكل ما عدا ذلك هو كلام في
التفاصيل اذا الان بعد 74 يوم ما الذي حدث
اسرائيل مرتبكه اسرائيل لانها فاشله في
الميدان تذهب الى هذه المجازر بالبث الحي
على يراها كل العالم ودون ان يكون هناك اي
احساس بالمجازر ضد المدنيين انا اقول لك
اخت خديجه احيانا احيانا المجازر ليست
مسموح بها فقط بل مطلوبه لاستعاده الردع
والا لتوقفت منذ
فتره المجازر التي تقوم بها اسرائيل اليوم
مع هذا التباكي الامريكي الغربي احيانا
الذي يلتبس على البعض لا هذه دموع
التماسيح التي تذرفها امريكا لتبيض صورتها
لتبييض هذا يعني تعريض صورتها وسقوط
الاقنعه عنها وانما المجازر اذا لم تكن
مسموح بها تكون هي مطلوبه لاستعاده الردع
على المنطقه وليس على غزه لانه الردع على
غز غزه انتهى ليس هناك رد على غزه في
الميدان المقاومه تتحكم في الميدان لا
زالت بعد 74 يوم تتحكم بالميدان وتدير
الميدان على المواجهه في قطاع غزه نرى
بالبث المباشر هذه الصور التي تخرج والتي
يعترف بها العدو رغم انه يعني لا يعلن عن
كل الخسائر وايضا في قصف اسرائيل تقصف
تلبين في اليوم ال 4ب اين ماذا يفعل الجيش
الاسرائيلي ماذا تفعل مئات الالاف حوالي
200 ال ويفعلون في غزه اذا كانت اسرائيل
تقصف تل ابيب بهذه الصواريخ في اليوم ال 7
وفي الميدان كل يوم يخرج مواجهات طيب هذا
الميدان لكن على المستوى هذا في الميدان
دكتور محمد الهندي على المستوى السياسي
قلت قبل قليل انه جاء السابع من اكتوبر
لينصف كل الترتيبات التي تمت في المنطقه
ولكن الى اليوم رغم كل ما يحدث المسؤولون
الامريكيون ما زالوا يتحدثون عن حل
الدولتين ربطه ب اكمال التطبيع استكمال
مسار التطبيع وتحديدا التطبيع السعودي
الاسرائيلي لا لا هذا لغو اخت خديجه هذا
لغو وكلام ليس له اي قيمه الذي سيقرر مصير
فلسطين غزه والضفه و بل ومصير اسرائيل وزن
اسرائيل الاستراتيجي
واهميتها الذي سيقرره هو نتيجه هذا هذه
المعركه نتيجه هذه المواجهه اما الحديث عن
الدولتين و قصه دولتين هذه فقط للخداع
خداع يعني بعض العرب
وال لا لا ليس هناك حلا امريكا لم تطرح لو
كان هناك حل لدولتين ماه 30 سنه بعدين مين
بيست طيع انه يقتلع 800000 مستوطن في
الضفه الغربيه اسرائيل امريكا العرب لا
يستطيع اقتلاع مستوطن واحد ما احنا شايفين
العرب لا يستطيع ادخال سله غذاء الى قطاع
غزه اذا هذا من باب الخداع هناك دوله اخرى
في الظفر الغربيه هي دوله المستوطنين وليس
هناك هدايا مجانيه ليس هناك يعني وجبات
تقدم لماذا لانه الفلسطيني يعني ابن حلال
ويؤمن بالسلام ما الا 30 سنه قدم قدم
واسلو على اساس حل الدولتين وماذا حدث
الكل مستسلم اذا لم تكن قويا اذا لم تاخذ
حقوقه في الميدان لن يعطيك لا يعطيك اياها
لا الامريكي ولا الاسرائيلي ولا اي قوه في
الدنيا هم يقيمون اعتبارا فقط للاقوياء
الان الشعب الفلسطيني نهض يدافع عن ارضه
وحتى الان يحقق انجازات في ارض المعركه
اسرائيل تهرب من من الفشل في في الميدان
الى هذه المجازر التي ط على ذكر الميدان
دكتور محمد لندي هناك حديث اسرائيلي وحديث
امريكي عن الانتقال الى مرحله جديده من
العمليات العسكريه وقبل قليل كان وليد
العمري يقول انه هذه المرحله التاليه سوف
تبدا مع نهايه الاسبوع الاول من الشهر
القادم باستهداف يعني بتحديد او التركيز
على اهداف معينه الى ان يتحقق الهدف
النهائي وهو اباده المقاومه تماما من قطاع
غزه ما قولكم اولا اولا اباده المقاومه
هذه مساله خلف ظهورهم المقاومه ليست بنايه
حتى يهدمو ولا حكومه حتى تسقط الشعب
الفلسطيني كله مقاومه وانا اقول لك الان
عندما من الذي يدافع عن الشعب الفلسطيني
الذي يدافع عن الشعب الفلسطيني هو
المقاومه سواء في الضفه الغربيه او في
قطاع غزه واسهم المقاومه وتاييد المقاومه
ترتفع في هذه اللحظات وهناك استطلاعات راي
كم في الم حتب استطلاع راي نشر الاسبوع
الماضي حوالي اكثر من 80% يطالبوا الرئيس
الفلسطيني بالاستقاله ولذلك وهم انه والله
نقضي على المقاومه لا هذا اجتثاث والحديث
عن مراحل هم تكلم الامريكان تحدثوا قبل
اسبوعين المرحله الاولى في شمال غزه والان
تنتقل اسرائيل الى جنوب غزه وحتى اليوم
القصف في الجنوب كما هو في الشمال الان
يتحدثون عن حجم الاستهداف المدنيين لم
يبقى في غزه شبر واحد لم يستهدف اذا كان
بيتكلموا عن حوالي 40,000 طن القيت على
غزه من 35 الى 40,000 طن كم مساحه غزه 360
مكم مربع يعني كل ك م مربع له 100 طن من
المتفجرات فاذا لم يبقى شيء لم يستهدف في
غزه وهم الان يقولون والله حجم الخسائر
بين مدنيين هذا التباكي والا طب ما هو طلع
من السكرتير العام للامم المتحده وكل
المؤسسات الدوليه والحقوق وتحدثت عن هذه
الجرائم هذه ليست فقط فقط قصف وانما هي
مجازر تجويع وهي استهداف للمستشفيات ولا
مستشفى في شمال غزه او في مدينه غزه صالح
للعمل الكل استهدف ولذلك هذا حرب اداده
للشعب الفلسطيني ما ما الذي تعنيه كلمه
الانتقال الى المرحله التاليه ما هو انا
اقول لك تقليل حجم المدنيين لانه الراي
العام في الغرب بدا يتمرد و وبايدن لديه
سنه انتخابيه تقليل انه لا فائده
استهدفتهم المدنيين ولم يتحقق اي هدف
لاسرائيل اسرائيل تاتي بهدف واحد يتحقق
الان تقصف الان تقصف تل ابيب والان
المقاومه تبث فيديوهات لاستهداف الجيش
الجيش معنوياته منهاره جيش اسرائيل
معنوياته منهاره جيش اسرائيل الان لا يحقق
اي اهداف ماحن شفناه بيشرب شيشه الجندي
اسرائيلي او الضابط في جنين والقضيه تنتقل
الى جنين الان هناك توتر اقليمي سواء في
البحر الاحمر او في جنوب لبنان لا تستطيع
امريكا احتواء هذا التوتر الاقليمي طب
ماذا تفعل امريكا اذا كان هي لا تستطيع
احتواء توتر اقليمي وموجوده سفنها من اول
يوم مدمرات في البحر المتوسط والبحر
الاحمر واذا كان هي الجيش الاسرائيلي رغم
كل هذه الامداد من امريكا 60 طائره محمله
بالذخائر في يوم واحد تصل اسرائيل واذا كل
هذا ولم يحقق اي انجاز سوى ضد المدنيين
والراي العام الدولي بدا يتحرك تقول له
خفف قليلا هي المرحله الثانيه استهدافات
مباشره طب ما هو لو كان يستطيع ان يستهدف
المقاومه بشكل مباشر لا استهدفهم هو لا
يوفر اي شيء لا يوفر المدنيين ولا الاطفال
ولا النساء ولذلك هذه جرائم تبث امام
العالم كله اما مساله والله خلافات بين
امريكا وبين اسرائيل وانه القضيه نتنياهو
مثلا كما يدعي البعض لا القضيه ليست
نتنياهو ولا حكومه نتنياهو المتطرفه
القضيه ان هذه الحرب تقودها امريكا والغرب
للحفاظ على ردع اسرائيل ومكانتها ووزنها
الاستراتيجي في المنطقه هذه هي المساله لا
اكثر ولا اقل اما الخداع بدولتين والخداع
بالمرحله الاولى والمرحله ثانيه الهدف
الواضح والمحدد هو اجتثاث المقاومه وهذا
الهدف لن يتحقق لذلك وبعدين هناك مسائل
ضاغطه الراي العام الاسرائيلي تبدد لانه
هناك عندهم رهائن ومدنيين وبداوا يقولون
نريد ابنائنا نذهب الى هدنه جديده مع انه
اخت خديجه الراي العام الاسرائيلي كله مع
الحرب اكثر من 92% من الاسرائيليين مع
الحرب واستمرار الحرب لكن يقولون نريد
ابنائنا احياء ولا نريد ان يقتلوا بعد ما
نعيد ابنائنا نذهب الى الى حرب مره اخرى
نذهب الى هدنه جديده لكن ان شاء الله اذا
كانت المسائل تسير بهذا الشكل ف النصر
سيكون حليف الشعب الفلسطيني الصامد الصابر
الضاغط على جراحه والمقاومه التي تديق
اسرائيل كل يوم فنون من المواجهه
رغم انه رغم انه المقاومه ربما تشعر بانها
لوحدها في الساحه وان نظريه وحده الساحات
لم تطبق وانه ربما ما كان معولا على حزب
الله لم يحدث بالمستوى
المطلوب يعني على كل حال انا الجبهه في
الجنوب لبنان لا الجبهه مشتعله وهناك
وايضا وهذه ضاغطه عندما كل يوم هناك في
مواجهات وايضا نحن نريد ان تبقى المساله
فلسطينيه وليست اقليميه هذه مساله اساسيه
في في هذا الصراع في هذه الجوله على الاقل
لكن الجبهه في الجنوب مشتعله وهناك حوالي
100000 مستوطن رحلوا من مستوطنات الشمال
الى قلب اسرائيل وهؤلاء يسببوا ضغط
بالاضافه الى المستوطنين الذين رحلوا من
غلاف غزه بنتكلم عن حوالي 200000 مستوطن
وايضا هناك هجره من اسرائيل هجره كبيره
الى قبرس والى البرازيل والى غيرها من
الدول اسرائيل بعد هذه الجوله لن تكون كما
كانت قبلها ولن يكون هناك ردع وزنها
استراتيجي سينهار سيتساءل العرب اذا كانت
هذه هي اسرائيل التي يعني يخوفون بها فهذه
ولا تصمد امام غزه اذا هذا الوهم الكبير
هذا العجز العربي سيدفن ضمن الاشياء التي
ستدفن الساديه والنازيه والعن جاهيه
الاسرائيليه ستدفن والعجز العربي سيدفن
واحلام امريكا في شرق اوسط جديد ستدفن
ايضا في هذه الجوله هذا صمود الشعب
الفلسطيني هو الاساس وايضا المقاومه
وتماسك المقاومه اما يعني الناس اللي
خوفونا في ال والله الامريكان جايين
والعرب عايزين وما في احد ما هذه الاوهام
تبدلت انا اقول لك مثلا العرب اللي انت
سالتي عنهم العرب ما قيمتهم ما وزنهم الان
يا اما متواطئين بشكل واضح دول انا بتكلم
عن الانظمه متواطئين او عاجزين او هؤلاء
يعني لا يملكون من امرهم شيء وصامتين ولا
يدرون اين يذهبون لكن هذا العجز سيتبدد ان
شاء الله به كان كان مستوى كان مستوى
تطلعهم للدور العربي اكبر يعني من مما هو
عليه والله انا ما هو اجتمعوا 57 دوله
اجتمعت 57 دوله في الرياض وقررت ان تشكل
لجنه واللجنه ستذهب الى دول العالم لتشرح
القضيه من اجل كسر الحصار و ما زلنا ننتظر
للاسف للاسف يعني للاسف هذا وزنهم لانه ما
عندهم اراده سياسيه هم يملكون كثير من
الاوراق ولكن هذه الاوراق معطله جدا هم
يعني 57 دوله بدهم يناشد العواصم
الاوروبيه والغربيه كيف يعني وانم ايش
بتعملوا انتم ثلث العالم العرب والمسلمون
ثلث العالم بدهم ناشدوا يروحوا لجنه
وزاريه تروح تشرح لموسكو وبكين طب ما هذه
الدول لديها مصالحها في المنطقه ولديها
رؤيتها للمنطقه يشرحوا للولايات المتحده
طب ما الولايات المتحده هي التي تقود
والدول الغربيه هي التي تقود هذه المعركه
لما يشرحون لمن يت هذا كله اوهام وعجز
تعكس العجز النظام العربي اللي موجود
اليوم وانا اقول لك يعني هذه الحرب هذه
المواجهه ستنعكس نتيجتها ليس فقط على
الوضع الفلسطيني الوضع الفلسطيني كله في
غزه وفي الضفه وفي كل مكان يعني وفي القدس
ان شاء الله اللي هي طوفان الاقصى ولكن
ايضا ستنعكس على وزن اسرائيل في المنطقه
هذه الهيمه وهذا الكبرياء اللي كانت
اسرائيل يعني تدعيه امام المنطقه وهذه
التحالفات التي ارادت ان تقيمها امريكا من
اجل السيطره والهيمنه على المنطقه والحفاظ
على مصالحها هنا كل هذا ان شاء الله
سيتبدد وهذا هو وهذا هو يفسر هذه المجازر
التي تقوم بها اسرائيل برعايه امريكيه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور محمد الهندي نائب
الامين العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي كنت
معنا من بيروت شكرا لك دكتور